so in 2019
um
that the Amazon fire started popping off
and we had just gone to to film uh like
a month earlier we'd filmed like a small
documentary and uh they'd been following
me as if I was on a as if I was on a
solo which you know we did the best we
could I let I lived on my own but we as
we were driving we passed a spot where
the Flames were 70 feet tall the forest
was being destroyed and I went out there
with my phone which overheated in like
two minutes and said you can't use it
but for a second I was out there in the
Flames picking up animals and throwing
them off to try and just get them cooled
off I was trying to get snakes out of
there everything was the birds are
flying and I [__] lost it I I was
red-eyed I was crying and I was going
this is happening every [__] day I
was screaming and it's the first time
that I'd done that because I've seen the
burning so many times and I just lost it
that day and I don't know what made me
pull out my phone because usually in
those intense moments I I say forget the
documentation this is real life we got
stuff to do and I'm doing I'm not
documenting and then a month later I'm
home and I'm in New York and all of a
sudden I see these articles like you
know the Amazon's burning worse this
year than it was last year and blah blah
blah and I was like this you know
[__] and I threw it up on Instagram
like eight o'clock at night
and I'd never like I'd never cursed on
Instagram I don't know you know why I
just never did and I my phone was on 100
and I put on top of the refrigerator and
I went to bed and I woke up in the
morning and my phone was on the floor on
two percent and it was ringing off the
hook
and it was like the news and they're
like are you the guy that posted that
viral video about the Amazon and I was
like what yeah and that was the start
that's where it broke and that's where
we went from Barefoot in the Amazon to
you know all of a sudden you know I was
talking ahead for three weeks and going
around on all these news stations and
all of a sudden I was like spokesperson
for the Amazon and JJ's calling me and
he was like go go go go go go like get
us get us that support and it was just
um you know so so communicating with
people and bringing them into that
reality and whether it's you know Rhino
poaching and elephant poaching or the
Amazon being destroyed it's like to me
it's like being able to to to take
people into that is is something that I
would love to do yeah and you do it
directly with authenticity on your
Instagram people should definitely
follow your Instagram I think I think
Rogan follows your Instagram too well
the end of that story actually kind of
involves him because yeah because
because I went to all these news outlets
and I was living in green rooms and
traveling around and I was all strung
out and I hadn't seen anybody I actually
know in a few weeks which was starting
to get to me and I finally got home and
I went to like a family party and
everyone's like dude you've been it's
been crazy and I was like yup and then I
left and my cousin Michael calls me and
he's screaming and I'm going what what
what what and he goes Joe Rogan just
shared it Joe Rogan just shared it oh
nice and everyone was losing their [__]
and it was so amazing and it was like
yeah that's when it really took off and
what happened as a result of all of this
is that a Canadian entrepreneur who
started light speed
um reached out and uh several months
later after covid after that boom
you know I'd been in the game for maybe
13 years or something had no money no
savings no job no nothing and after that
great publicity thing
nothing happened
the waves came and everything got real
exciting everybody reached out and they
said we care so much
nothing happened though you know we can
run into battle but if we don't have our
arrows in the quiver
what can we do
and I actually I made a phone call to my
friend moson right at the start of covid
and I was going through divorce and I
was broke
and I said
I'm gonna get a job
I said I give up
this is stupid I said the ecotourism
business has done jungle Keepers has
dried up
we're done and then this guy daxed a
Silva called me on the phone and said
listen I'm in what what do we got to do
and so if if the analogy was me and JJ
and a few other people trying to hold
this Boulder back from just destroying
the rainforest all of a sudden Dax comes
in like a Titan and just puts his arm
out and just goes I'm gonna help
and he gave us the funding to start
actually developing a ranger program to
start actually bringing loggers to be
Protectors of the forest to be
supporting smaller conservation things
and now we're protecting 50 000 Acres of
rainforest we're protecting entire
streams and ecosystems that I love and
we're soon going to double that and it's
like this this whole thing so
um yeah the the the the the
communication of these things is crucial
and I actually think it's incredible
that that social media has played such a
big role in it well I mean uh just just
because I I know Joe well and I love him
so much I I definitely think uh you
should do his podcast but also just be
friends with him I think you guys
um he's one you know not the meme but
he's one with nature and not much more
with the I'm one while I do appreciate
and love nature I also love
um technology I know yeah and robots and
so on so we're in that Meme type of way
we're very very different but well
either way at some point make sure you
tell the guy thank you because it
definitely really helped push us over
that that limit where you know if enough
people see it you get someone like Dax
who who who says I can help and I have
the resources to help
and that and that changed our whole
lives sees everything